[Music]
hey you guys
it's tomes of terror once again got
another really really good one
oh i'm so excited to talk about this one
this is a great [ __ ] book okay
so this is the 2014
novel no one gets out alive
by adam neville now what happened with
this one
was that i kept seeing this [ __ ] turning
up on pretty much
every booktube show like
you know on youtube that i watch
everybody was just raving about this
book
he's written a bunch of other um novels
prior to this but this is the first one
that i had read because i was like i
read like a slight synopsis and i was
like no no
don't tell me uh you know and so i just
wanted to like go into it completely
blind
which i would recommend because i really
didn't have
any idea what to expect and i like that
better like i kind of got the idea that
this is sort of like
a haunted house-y kind of thing but it's
really it is but it has a lot of other
kind of stuff going on too
and i liked that i didn't really see
where it was going however that said
i'm probably gonna i'm not gonna spoil
the entire plot or anything like that
but i am gonna talk about some stuff
you know where the plot goes some of the
things that are going on
in the story that maybe you might want
not wanna know like ahead of time
so if you haven't read it then obviously
you might want to go read it first or if
you don't care you can just
listen to the [ __ ] and do whatever you
want to do man it's like you know it's
your life now there's one thing i will
say
this book is long
okay i don't know that doesn't bother me
i'm just i'm just
telling you ahead of time it's about 620
something pages
uh that's the reason actually that i did
night of the mannequins by stephen
graham jones last week because that book
was so short
that i wanted because i wanted to have
time to read this one you know what i
mean so i wanted to give myself like an
extra week
and it actually didn't take me as long
to finish this as i thought it would
because
it was a really like compelling story i
have seen some reviewers say that they
wish it had been shorter
by like 100 or 200 pages because they
thought maybe it dragged a little bit in
the middle
i can see that that criticism but it
didn't really bother me to any great
degree
it didn't seem that long to me i was
pretty invested in the characters i was
pretty interested to see what was going
on
so it didn't bother me so your mileage
may vary
but i'm just pointing out that that some
reviewers even the reviewers that really
really liked it
said you know maybe 100 200 pages could
have been trimmed out of it
and it would have been even better but i
don't know
like i said everybody's mileage is going
to vary on that it didn't seem long to
me
but so what is this story about so adam
neville is a
british novelist as i said this came out
in 2014. i haven't read any of his other
ones but i probably
will after after reading this one and i
liked this one so much
so this is set in birmingham
england now our main character is named
stephanie booth
and she's this young woman i guess she's
you know 20 in her early 20s or whatever
i guess she's kind of been through some
[ __ ] where her mom died when she was
pretty young
and then her dad ended up marrying this
herodin who hated her and then when her
dad died
the loon stepmother basically kicked her
out of the house
so for a little while like i said they
don't go too much in her past but
there's just kind of like that's just
sort of the setup
and i guess she had a boyfriend named
ryan they'd been together a couple years
but then they kind of broke up there
wasn't like any big thing there it's
like she just kind of wanted to
make her way on her own so she decides
to move away
from her hometown of stoke and all her
friends and her ex-boyfriend and her
horrible stepmother
and she's gonna make her own way uh in
birmingham
now probably unwisely
like you know i i can see why you'd want
to do that
and you know fresh start and all that
but
she doesn't really have much money to
her name
she's been working for a temping agency
and you know shit's tough all over and
she hasn't really been able to
get anything long-term it's just kind of
like a few days of work here and there
and it's just kind of shitty jobs like
call centers and
giving out food samples at supermarkets
and [ __ ] like that
so she's really trying to scrape
together um you know some money get
a job and everything like that so she's
looking for
a cheap place to live and she stumbles
across this ad
for a house at 82 edge hill road
that is renting out rooms to girls only
now renting out rooms at 40 pounds a
week which is super super cheap
so she's pretty jazzed about this and
she goes to see the place and it's kind
of this creepy old victorian
house that's really seen much better
days
and she is kind of like well the room
seems okay she's like it's a little bit
dirty it's
a little bit old it's a little bit dated
but the landlord
this dude named [ __ ] mcguire he's um
kind of sleazy a little bit but
she's kind of in a jam it's like she
can't really afford anything
you know better than this and she really
you know it isn't getting much of
anything from the temp agency she really
needs a place to stay
she's sort of on her own so she kind of
seems to
quickly you know overlook any bad things
and
give him the deposit money and you know
one or two weeks or a month in advance i
think she gives him
because he's sitting there saying oh
it's you know it's gonna be fine we're
doing this place all up and
it'll it'll be so much better we're
gonna modernize it and all this other
kind of crap so she moves in
now pretty much from her first night
in this [ __ ] she realizes that she
has made a terrible terrible mistake
not just because [ __ ] maguire the
landlord
is kind of creepy and not so much he's
not so much creepy as in hey i'm gonna
come in and paw through your underwear
drawer kind of thing
but he just seems real shady you know
what i mean and he's he's like a chav
like you know what i mean that's how he
came across to me like very much just
kind of this
this chad who was always kind of like
he's very arrogant he's very
condescending but he's really
trashy you know what i mean so he's that
type of dude he says it's his parents
house that it's his mother's house
they've died they've inherited it
him and his cousin and they're doing it
up and all this other kind of [ __ ] which
turns out
you know spoiler alert to be a lie but
that's what he tells her so the first
night she's in this house
immediately like some creepy creepy [ __ ]
starts happening
she starts hearing like something that
sounds like plastic or polythene like
crinkling under the bed um she hears
what sounds like women crying um coming
from like behind the fireplace or maybe
it's
in the next room and you know she hears
a woman crying or a woman talking like
and it seems like it's coming out of the
bathroom drain
so she keeps hearing like all this
creepy ass noise
and it's like at first she's not really
sure if it's like supernatural because
[ __ ] the landlord has told her it's
like yeah we're gonna rent out you know
all these rooms to some girls there's
other girls living here or
he's kind of sketchy about it's like
there's either other girls already
living here or there's gonna be other
girls living here
now she hasn't seen anybody else if
there's like a shared bathroom and a
shared
uh kitchen and i think it's like three
floors or something like that the ground
floor is blocked off you can't go down
there
um but the top two floors uh are kind of
like there's a shared bathroom and then
the
[ __ ] and his cousin who comes into it
later uh
i think they live on the top but so
she's not really sure
if there's already some other girls
living in there and she thinks somebody
you know maybe needs help
but you know she knocks on the wall or
the door or whatever and nobody answers
and then like some more overtly
supernatural [ __ ] starts happening where
she's she feels somebody like sitting on
the bed
and she turns the light on real quick
and there's nobody there you know she
starts seeing shadows like hearing
footsteps like that kind of crap
i mean fair play to her the first night
that she endures this and she doesn't
really get much sleep and she has kind
of a temp assignment the next morning
so she's kind of like okay um i have to
get the [ __ ] out of here because i'm not
you know sleeping in this room she's
like i can't sleep in there there's all
kind of like haunting [ __ ] going on it's
terrifying
and i just i'm not having it so she
goes to [ __ ] and tries to get her
deposit back
and at this point you get a thing where
he's basically holding the deposit money
over her head because
you know she has only had a couple days
of work she doesn't really have any
money
and she can't get another room until
this do she gives her money back and he
knows that
he knows that she's desperate because
he's been sort of spying on her
um so he knows that he kind of has her
by the short and curlies
another criticism that i saw of this was
that stephanie
seemed a little bit like too passive or
she didn't really you know just run out
of the place screaming as soon as
you know [ __ ] started to go sideways
because [ __ ] does go very
very sideways in this house like in
many more ways than you could probably
imagine you know but
in a way though because we're it's not
in the first person but we're pretty
much like inside her head the whole time
like you know it's limited third person
so you know what she's thinking and what
she's going through
and in a way like i could really i could
see
yes she was kind of passive yes she was
trying to be nice to people when
maybe they didn't deserve it but i could
see
i could relate to her character because
i you know i'm a little bit like that
i've known some people that are kind of
like that you kind of want to try to
make the best of the situation
shake look i don't have any money what
am i supposed to do am i supposed to
sleep out on a
bench she didn't really have anybody she
could call um you know she texts her
ex-boyfriend at one point like in the
next town and she's like hey can i
crash on your couch or can i borrow some
money or something he's with another
girl
friend at this time so he doesn't really
want to get involved
so there's all this other kind of [ __ ]
she you know her friends don't really
want to know
and they're in another town anyway so
it's kind of she's kind of stuck
so in a way yeah it's kind of easy to
say you know why don't you just run the
[ __ ] out of there
but she does kind of go through every
scenario of like what can i do what can
i do
she so she just kind of keeps kicking it
down the road like well you know when i
get paid for my temp job at the end of
this week then i'll
you know then i'll find another room i
only have to stay here for another three
nights and there or then maybe i can go
find a hostel and then i can figure out
what i can do from there
so it is like she's trying to make the
best of the situation
but in a way uh particularly because of
her financial situation because of her
being in a
town where she doesn't know anybody and
she's really isolated you know there's
really not
she doesn't really have a lot of choices
and then it's
almost too kind of like [ __ ] is sort
of manipulating her
holding the you know promise of giving
her deposit back like over her head
and then you know she's like oh i'll
give you a better room because she's
like i'm not sleeping in that [ __ ]
haunted ass room anymore
so he gives her a better one but then he
just you know it
he does [ __ ] like he'll do that and like
he'll pretend to be nice to her but then
later on down the line it's like oh well
the rent for that was way higher so now
you owe me all this money so he's doing
that kind of crap
so the thing about this book that's so
great
is that there yes there is supernatural
elements
um threaded throughout the first um
probably two-thirds of the book because
this book is in two parts which i'll get
to in a minute
but there's supernatural elements
threaded throughout in the sense that
she keeps like hearing [ __ ] in this
house and eventually well it doesn't
even take that long it's not even
eventually but
she comes to the realization that these
are
ghosts that so the house is either
haunted or she's going nuts you know one
of those two things so she comes to that
realization
but the thing about it is that the
ghosts are almost like
on the back burner for the first two
thirds just because
the [ __ ] that's going on in real life in
the house like the real people
like [ __ ] mcguire and his cousin
fergal
the [ __ ] that they are doing is like
worse than the ghosts because these two
vile shitheaded dudes
are just kind of like and like i said if
this is going to be all
kind of like plot spoilers and [ __ ] like
that so it's like if you haven't read
this book
then go read it and then come back you
know like i said i'm not gonna spoil
everything that happens in it but
it's a really hard book to talk about if
you can't
talk about what happens in it like all
of the different plot threads and
everything
so so there is ghost [ __ ] and haunting
[ __ ] like i said at the beginning
but the two cousins essentially what
they're doing
is they're attracting they're trying to
get women
in there and they're trying to run a
brothel
so they're doing human trafficking
pretty much so they bring in two
girls at some point who know that
they're going into prostitution
right they know that they're going there
to be sex workers they're not happy
about the living accommodations because
apparently [ __ ] had told them that it
was it all been done up and it was much
nicer
than it was so they get there and
they're like what is this [ __ ] we
don't want to live here
but you know they came there to be
prostitutes so they knew what they were
getting in for
stephanie it seems like they're trying
to soft sell her
into being a sex worker as well
so they're trying to get her into so
they're trying to like manipulate her
now
[ __ ] is more like even though he's a
skeeze
he's kind of more like the sales pitch
kind of guy
you know what i mean but fergal is more
like
the muscle like he is just this big
brutish
he's just super super tall he's like
seven feet tall he's like this
freakishly and he's all freakishly
skinny and stuff but he
you know they've all been in prison
they're just all these [ __ ] shifty
ass [ __ ] characters
and it gets to a point where you know
they're essentially trying to force her
into prostitution like you know they're
tying the girls in the house they're
like threatening to
throw acid on their faces they're doing
all that kind of [ __ ]
so it's like it's bad enough that this
[ __ ] house is haunted right but then
all this other [ __ ] is going on too and
stephanie
gets to a point where you know she tried
to leave she tried to leave she tried to
leave but then there comes a point where
it's like too late and she can't leave
so it's just this the first like
two-thirds of it are really harrowing
and the thing about it too is that the
two cousins
they seem to know something about the
supernatural [ __ ] that's going on in the
house and the supernatural [ __ ]
seems to be related to not only
the brothel that they're trying to run
nowadays
but also to the dude that used to live
in the house
and maybe even the people that lived in
the house before that like
when it was even built so
as i said this book is in two parts the
first two thirds of it is set over
stephanie's nine days in this house
which catalogs so it's it's you know
each kind of section is one day like one
long day
so it kind of talks about the haunting
how the haunting is ramping up
and then it's talking about how she just
keeps getting in deeper and deeper
more and more like uh you know
threatened by the cousins
and how they're essentially forcing her
that you know they lock her in
and all these other kind of things
there's horrible right now i'm going to
say this is a very very
violent book like a lot of people get
the [ __ ] beat out of them and it's you
know pretty graphically
uh described um there's a lot of rape in
this
so if that's gonna bother you sure
this is not the book for you i'm just
saying that right now
so the first two thirds is like that and
then at the end of the nine days when
stephanie
escapes and gets out and won't spoil
like how that all comes about or
anything like that
but then interestingly it jumps ahead
three years now at this point
it was like the the up was so jarring
that it was almost like a whole new
different story
so i will admit that when the second
part started like when after the time
jump for a second i was just kind of
like wait wait
like what's going on here you know what
i mean so it was kind of like it took me
a few pages to kind of get into the
swing of
what was going on because like the tone
of it is a little bit different
you know what i mean so it's almost kind
of like it goes off in a different
direction sort of but what happens
after that is that so she escapes from
this house
you know the cops come in they have to
you know there are just bodies
everywhere
and they have they excavate the property
they tear it down it's all this other
kind of stuff it's this huge
media sensation because of all the
people that have been killed there like
over the past hundred years and all this
other
stuff so what ends up happening is that
three years later
she has basically sold her story like
she wrote a book and that was made into
a movie and also so she
um actually got really rich but
she still wholeheartedly believes that
the spirit
in the house at 82 edgehill road
are still tormenting her and in
particular
it's not just the spirits of the people
that died there although it is that
but there's also kind of a
force that is
i almost want to say it's like like a
folk horror
type of thing so it's like one of those
like ancient just i don't want to say
witchcraft but it's kind of but it's
kind of like that
so the second part of the book is kind
of her she's got a new identity and all
and she lives in this like massive
uh this big farm house that she that's
out in the middle of nowhere and she has
all these security guards and
uh you know all this other so because
she's still like afraid because one of
the dudes you know she thinks is still
looking for her
and she's also like still kind of
tormented by
all of the spirits of the uh victims and
other people that died at the house
and by this force this spirit
this being that seems to want to come
after her
so the second part of the book
even though it's a lot different i guess
tonally than the first part the second
part is much
more concerned with the supernatural
aspect you know what i mean because like
i said the first part of the book is
you know it has supernatural a lot of
supernatural elements in it because
like i said she's constantly hearing
footsteps and
hearing noises and you know at some
point she gets put down in the first
like the the ground floor that's been
closed off and like all this
horrible kind of [ __ ] climactic thing
happens
and um she kind of figures out you know
tries to get a handle on what the hell
is going on in this house and
what [ __ ] and fergal like know about
it but it's more the first part of the
book is much more about the human
monsters and how they are you know
forcing her how she got forced into this
uh situation and how she kind of finds
her inner strength and try to
get out of it and then the second part
is much more about the aftermath like
about
what the media attention did to her um
you know how nobody
you know she told everybody about the
supernatural aspects and stuff and no
one believed her
and you know so that kind of uh element
comes into play as well
so you kind of get a thing between her
and the person that is her like her
you know personal security guard and
they have to kind of battle this ancient
being that is still after her
you know what i mean okay so that's all
so that's what i'm gonna say about that
so that's what this book is about
i mean this was a really great like
immersive book one of the best things
about this book is that
even at the beginning part like while
the supernatural stuff was just kind of
on the margins
you know the the human horror was so
potent i mean because i've been in
situations like that where you had to
where you didn't have any money and you
had to like move into this place and it
was like kind of shitty and
you just felt like you didn't really
have any choices because you were so
broke and it's like
and this poor and i felt so bad for this
poor girl
who was just trying to make the best of
things she was just trying to
you know better her life she's like i
wanted you to live on my own i'll get a
job i'll you know i'll find a nicer
place to live this place is only it's
kind of shitty but it's only temporary
and she was so optimistic and then it's
just as
things just got suckier and suckier and
suckier i mean
to a degree that like like i said you
probably can't even imagine like how
[ __ ] horrible this [ __ ] got and i
just felt
so so bad for her and then so so i
really did like relate to her i know
that some people criticize and they're
at the beginning oh she was too passive
she should have got the [ __ ] out of
there earlier
but you know it i can totally see it's a
totally
realistic progression you know what ends
up happening to her and how she ended up
in that situation
and you know i i think it's a little
victim blamey to
kind of say oh she should have done this
that the other thing i know she's just a
book character but
you know i'm just saying that you don't
know what you would do in that situation
and i could totally see [ __ ] going down
exactly
this way if you were broke if you didn't
really have any other options
uh for a place to live or any friends or
any you know backup or anything like
that
i can totally see [ __ ] happening [ __ ]
going down like this
and then adding on this horrific
supernatural element which makes
everything like 100 times worse and i
just felt so so bad for her
and so like as the story goes on you
know as the first two-thirds of the book
goes on and she
really kind of just finds that strength
in order to like find finally like fight
back
and just say [ __ ] it you know even if i
get killed i really need to [ __ ] sort
this [ __ ] out
and it's just really really satisfying
so i think that was a really good
she has a really good character arc is
what i'm saying now as i said
it is a little jarring when you go from
the first two thirds of the book to the
second you know
after when it jumps ahead three years
but stick with it because there's like
some really cool
[ __ ] in that section as well i think i
like the first section
better but i did like that the second
section
kind of resolved what exactly this
ancient being was that we were dealing
with what exactly
had been going on in that house and had
been going on there even before [ __ ]
and fergal like took it over
i i liked that all that was resolved
even though i think that the first
two thirds of the book was probably like
more compelling just because
i liked the atmosphere of the house
because
just the way adam neville described it
it's like you can almost [ __ ] smell
the place you know what i mean it's just
i could just picture him as
grimy [ __ ] nasty disgusting
place that's like never cleaned and it's
like these big gross ass
like things of dust and mouse turds and
it was just like everything was
disgusting and
greasy and like everything so it's like
you could really just kind of like
picture it in your mind
and like i said i felt so bad for the
main character because
you know like i said everybody's
everybody has been broke and you had to
like live somewhere that was
really not um ideal and so i really kind
of related pretty hard to her situation
and uh you know and i really so i really
really liked like her character arc
but yeah now the this is a very long
book it is a commitment as i said
some people complained that you know
even if they liked it we're like i could
have been a little bit shorter
i don't you know i don't agree i don't
disagree i think that's like a
that's subjective uh i to me it didn't
really seem very long it only took me
you know two or three days you know over
a couple hours a day like to read it
didn't take me that long to read it
so it didn't seem all that long to me
but you know your mileage may vary as
always uh but yeah i mean
if this you know if this is how awesome
his uh
other books are which i've heard that um
his other books are also
quite awesome he did one called the
house of small shadows i think it was
that
has also gotten a lot of praise which
came out a year or two before this one
so i'll probably be checking that one
out at some point as well
so yeah that'll do it for this tomes of
terror book review and i will see you
guys on the next one
bye